all right guys
thank you for coming together uh i know
you guys are enjoying your christmas
break right now but i'm gonna put you to
work because we are going through an
emergency and apparently
jk ain't [ __ ] without steve and we need
to do something that's what i read too
everyone's mad right now way too asian
dude way too asian fox
i don't know man i think that we're
pretty good without
steve and we can probably move on but i
think for the first time in jk history
i'm really concerned and i'm really
reading the comments and maybe i should
do something about it so how do we get
our favorite white guy back
so that's kind of tough i
since he moved here i've been trying to
link up with him
and i don't know if i could do it by
myself but i tried to knock on his door
text him a couple of times and he kind
of just like ghosts me and he got a
[ __ ] like he said bro text me at my
702 number i'm like dude you're from l.a
dude why you gotta hit me with that las
vegas aerial code
ever since that fool became a
millionaire on crypto yeah he's changed
man he's big time in us i do think
though if we want him back
um
that he probably is lonely
so if we can go get him
and remind him of how good of a of a
time we had as the careful boys
i think there might be a chance if we go
get him i think
but we can't tell them that though oh
yeah
yeah so we're gonna go get em or what
i think we should work
are you guys free are you guys down
i'm in hawaii but i can i can fly down
we have to wine and dine him and maybe
you know
69 him
all right i'm skeptical but i'm up for
it let's go let's do it all right
all right you guys vegas
say vegas on three
no we're not doing that come on dude
come on
in the middle put our hands in but all
right
three one two one
all right i guess we're going to vegas
[Music]
you really don't think somebody i don't
think something i think that's the wrong
mindset i think if we can remind them of
the friendship that we've had
and entice them bring them out and i
think we can actually work we should
drop mollies together i think that'll
work then we can like confess to each
other like true emotions and stuff and
then have like this bonded brother it's
so deep that like and i could finally
grab his wiener oh yeah yeah hold it in
your hand a lot of wiener grabbing guys
right that's the goal all we gotta do is
show them what it's like to be with the
careful boys again you know he misses us
he's in his room making all this money
on crypto and we got to remind them life
is more than just making a ton of money
yeah but that's what the key is right
there is that we end up associating
everything he sees in vegas with us
we taint vegas for him we take him to
everything that he's gonna see daily and
we add ourselves to that so he can't
unsee us everywhere he looks and then he
misses us and he comes back right
what the [ __ ] are you guys doing here
so steve man been a while dude how's it
been man
i'm [ __ ] killing it honestly really
life's been good i've been happier
impossible like what
you're talking about what's better about
your life that's true i got a beautiful
ass house you gotta beautify his wife
it's true yeah but how about how about
friends
dude i got tons of friends with vegas
it's crazy you meet people just meet
people on the street and then all of a
sudden they think you've been your best
friend your whole life really what about
moisturized friends not dry ass friends
um well that's true the people are
pretty dry here yeah see i think you're
missing some friendships from real
friendships and real memories
i think i'm missing moisturized friends
moisturized humid friends you guys are
good at making arguments gotta give you
that always be good though exactly so
what i'm thinking is this i think it's
on the honeymoon phase of vegas and i
don't think the real pain of friendship
has really hit you yet yeah so i want to
take you up
remind you how good of a time that we
used to have
and hopefully you'll um come back to
la to
shoot a
non-specific youtube channel
you get serious
yeah that's why you guys are here he was
trying to get me back on jk yeah no
one's talking about jake
you know no it's more like a hangout
yeah yeah like like in l.a like and
we're talking but like hey might as well
like turn on the camera ten to six yeah
yeah and then maybe talk about manscape
here and there yeah
it sounds like a jake issue no it's not
it's only gonna be at the office there
because it feels good yeah and then we
could get free lunch you know
do we have the arcade machine still yeah
do we
i know you guys were pretty much hogged
the whole time i was over there
but yeah would you be down to come hang
out with us just for a little time sake
and then see if
you know this this bridge of friendship
is still there i'll tell you this right
now
i'm willing to hang out there's no
[ __ ] way i ever set foot on jk again
let's just let's just hang out and see
where this goes yeah yeah i think you'll
come around i think she'll drink a
little bit more of this yeah we'll go
hang out and a little more of that one
and then at the end of the trip we'll
have you sign something and don't worry
about it don't worry about it yeah what
part you have a place right you know
oh yeah yeah so i already have a place
in mind the first place
that i think is gonna be so fun like
this is why i want to hang out with the
boys
you gotta swear sweatshirts sweat
love it dude yeah
i can't go anywhere guys i can't go
anywhere
why not
i got a package coming like three hours
i can't miss it what is it it's my
non-shrimp hat
the the noodle
what are you talking about you guys know
what non-shim is i know what it is he's
delicious
yeah it's my new hat it's it's like the
top brand of like insane right yeah
thanks players
[Music]
steve why don't you even like here in
vegas dude look around
beautiful women beautiful mountains
artificial lakes they're cleaner the
ducks even like them even more we got
swans that's what i saw lots of swans
what are you doing what do you mean
we're trying to get him to come home not
stay out here even more love vegas
oh dude vegas it's so bad
see
that means good dude he's talking it's
like it's a language thing
it's so bad like so good right
[Music]
[Music]
all right steve i know what you missed
the most about just kidding news
taika stories
why don't you tell me to tell the story
bro
see this right here
he's on his pajamas
he sleeps
and guess what
he used to
pee in his bed
right
but now
he doesn't eat anymore he's potty
trained
but
his favorite of all time
noodles
yeah you know bart you might not uh
believe this but i actually don't really
miss type of stores
really
yeah none of us miss tyka's stories man
right i'm kind of the same right yeah
right yeah yeah why are we what are we
doing here anyway right steve yeah
yeah somebody anybody yeah this was
stupid right yeah no dude
you don't even know what steve likes but
i you know what i think i have a pretty
good idea and we can go there right now
dude like yeah it's going to blow your
mind blow your mind yeah
oh i can't wait to get the hell out of
here let's go yeah we're just jumping
here yeah we're just okay
i have control over cast if i come back
of course dude i definitely want to make
some changes but we can talk about that
let's let's go to the place it's gonna
yeah you're gonna love it all right
the buffet
at his favorite casino circus circus
i've never said it's my favorite casino
but it is
an incredible casino
let's go
starting with steve's culture i know you
can't resist
things of your hometown we've got corn
dogs
we got chicken strips
mac and cheese
boiled vegetables no that's not my
culture though i could feel the
excitement coming from his heart
thank you brother you're [ __ ]
bothering me thank you one of your
favorite things to do is to eat with us
during jk news i just want to bring back
those memories
it's like i'm all man
excuse isn't this great
right we could be doing this again
on jk news eating together it could be
like good old times you know
yes but i live in vegas so i can do this
anything i want you know damn you got me
there yeah just because you live in
vegas
even though you can drink in vegas
you can drink with me at any time
and that's one of the things that i
believe is why you love jk someone
[ __ ] drink with me nah just the
[ __ ] place to take you right now so
you can rekindle that memory and the
glory of what it is
to enjoy a good day with me
i don't think i'm ready to rejoin jk yet
but i'm willing to hear you out
[Music]
dude she did did she miss the boys man
just hanging bro
i don't know
no it's no it's not working
it's not working because it wasn't the
drinking with you
that he loved it was the [ __ ] on you
it's all times you were cheating on
anthony i'll show you exactly what i
mean come on
yeah
i think i remember that
[Music]
you know how you love jab walkers
i love that you do right i've always
loved that but did you ever think about
why you love jab walking so much
i guess it's because
i really [ __ ] hate candles
i see what you're saying because i say
[ __ ] kinses all the time
oh so that's what that's why
i get it
[ __ ] hinges [ __ ] ninjas this is the
[ __ ] story so how could you possibly
live in vegas away from us knowing that
anytime you look at job walkies which is
everywhere you look in vegas you're
going to be seeing
the kinshops i'll come back to jk
i have an idea bob it's a condition i'll
come back to jk but i get to buy all the
all the jab walkies merch i want right
now and anthony has to pay for it with
the kendra's card
i think he would do that for you let's
make it happen guys let's do it all
right let's see let's take a page let's
take a photo yeah
[Music]
oh is everybody nice
yeah my bad one more well that's your
brand that's very cool
[Music]
[Music]
i think that uh kind of worked
you feel like you're coming around
i think i'm getting close
all right this is how i know we're gonna
seal the deal you ready for this what do
we like to do on jks we like to look at
hot babes oh yeah we like look at all
the fine ladies that we talk about the
stories yeah right yeah so i know a
place that we can go
where it's nothing but hot chicks really
yes are you down hot chicks and hard
bodies we don't tell none of our wives
okay or girlfriends or whatever you guys
down i'm down hot babes i promise
[Music]
what's wrong
[Music]
steve that was so stupid that's what you
meant by girls did you guys all see the
hot babes walking in there was tons of
them what
you mean in the audience that's what you
meant
that's where they all are steve doesn't
want that that's what you want
i accept you dude how are we gonna get
them back all of that you got stupid
ideas that was the closest you came that
heartwarming story oh boy your ideas
then you had to bring us over there i
thought fat tuesdays he doesn't drink
alcohol dude not like that no i don't
drink the sugar stuff but it's okay it
was a nice try sorry guys i guess we're
never gonna get them back now because of
you guys we came out here for nothing
why live here you're not even helping
because you make them feel like you
should stay in vegas that's it man jk is
over
there's no way we got him back there's
nothing you want to do we lost our
diversity card
you know what guys
[ __ ] it there is one way
that i come back and do a bunch of jk
vids really what
[Music]
live
at the trump tower this is her new jk
news
we are live we are finally here at the
trump tower why because we did off the
record about this you thought we were
joking well we were and then we made it
serious because steve here wouldn't come
back to jk news unless we filmed here so
because steve is a big trump supporter
we decided why not
why not do it all right oh you switched
sides
dude this is your idea 2022 is a
different time we want to bring all of
our audience together and that's why
we're wearing biden hats and trump hats
today
this was a mistake
[Music]
is jk isn't just j fujitsukawa and k for
kwan it's also n for nick
e
for ryan emay
w
for anthony wong
yeah
s is for steve steve he's the s
yeah you really made that one work
preach baby preach i mean wow that's
true i forgot that everyone's letters
are in there yeah w for anyone